les élections européennes avec tout
d'abord ce sondage publiés demain par la
tribune de l'expansion réalisé par la
sofres
on y constate un coude à coude entre les
listes ps et udf rpr la liste fabius est
créditée de 28% des voix tout juste un
petit point devant la liste vge
derrière on constate la progression de
la liste centriste de madame simone veil
crédité de 13% 1 point devant antoine
waechter les écologistes sont à 12 le
front national jean marie le pen
recueille 9 pour recueillir et 9% des
voix et le pcf philippe herzog est
actuellement située à 7 5% des voix
les européennes avant naturellement ces
résultats il ya la campagne campagne
lancée pour l'opposition udf rpr la
liste conduite par valérie giscard
d'estaing et alain juppé présentation
des 64 sur 80 premiers candidats de la
liste aujourd'hui un lieu choisi
symboliquement il s'agit du futuroscope
de poitiers peu de surprises dans ce
classement
michel lemaire
la liste udf rpr est en marche pas de
grosse surprise effectivement dans sa
composition
les quatre premiers noms étaient déjà
connus alain juppé et françois lyotard
sont en deuxième et troisième positions
en quatre michèle barzach précède le
président du parti radical yves galland
parmi les personnalités qui ne passeront
pas inaperçus dit cook et où et robert
hersant en 19e position
on y trouve aussi des noms symboliques
comme ceux de charles de gaulle le
petit-fils du général et alain qu'on
pidoux c'est le fils du prédécesseur car
elle ne pense pas une seconde au passé
pendant cette campagne
depuis le début de mon activité dans la
vie politique
j'ai pensé que le grand événement
s'installeront sur le plan politique un
certain renouvellement plusieurs
sortants n'ont pas été reconduits un
autre signe pas tout à fait innocent en
direction des rénovateurs à l'impôt
place à des pris position en leur faveur
et puis la présence j de plusieurs
séries mais le simple fait d'avoir
organisé cette manifestation au
futuroscope en pleine terre cds était
déjà une sorte de défi aux centristes